it's been 21 days of mass disturbances
and demonstrations in Chile and amid
mounting criticism for not controlling
the violence that often accompanies
peaceful protests president sebastián
piñera addressed the nation with a
series of measures we want to announce a
public agenda to strengthen public order
and better safeguard our citizens
security
we've lived days of tremendous violence
vandalism and delinquency provoked in
most cases by groups of organized crime
the tempo and plan includes outlawing
barricades and the use of masks and
other methods to disguise one's face
including and boosting the role of
intelligence services and the use of
helicopters during protests among others
Wednesday the Uptown headquarters of the
conservative OD party which is part of
Panera's governing coalition were
attacked and ransacked we are facing
coordinated and organized groups who are
acting in a directed way we need to
investigate this so that we can find the
leaders of these violent groups who are
causing destruction our intelligence
system wasn't prepared for this type of
urban violence the threat of higher
penalties hasn't dissuaded protesters
with the mass demonstrations moving
uptown to an area that had been
considered off-limits a kind of an oasis
of peace in the middle of three weeks of
demonstrations but as you can see this
area which is the epicenter if you like
the headquarters of the biggest
businesses in the country are now being
closed and surrounded by protesters
while most protesters insist they don't
support violence some argue the current
upheaval is a necessary evil
Pinero says he listens to peaceful
protests but what about those who have
been demonstrating for more than four
years for better pensions if those who
started those protests had written a
letter to the president instead of
rushing the metro would the president
have listened No
while Pineda called for a rare emergency
meeting of Chile's National Security
Council opposition members and
demonstrators accused the president of
trying to criminalize the protests while
others lamented that he had not been so
energetic about increasing penalties to
curtail police brutality you see in
human aljazeera Santiago